what's going on guys
we are knee-deep in something epic and
historic f XX is airing every Simpsons
episode ever back to back to back to
back I keep saying back to back because
there's so many of them The Simpsons
they've been with us forever and we're
gonna break down why we love the
Simpsons right here today and we have a
couple awesome guests to talk about it
with first she is an actress and
comedian and just a delightful human
being thanks he'll certainly hailey
Mancini thanks for being here thanks for
having me
and this gentleman is one of the stars
of IFC's the birthday boys he was a
writers assistant on The Simpsons Mike
Mitchell thanks for being here right
here for having me I'll just throw this
out to both of you why have the Simpsons
been around for over 550 episodes and a
movie what's the key to their staying
power why do we love them at the end of
it they are a nuclear family and I mean
that's why it's still popular in
countries everywhere I don't want to get
too controversial okay but um is it
worth it watching the marathon after
season 8 airs I would say after season
10 I'll go up to season 10 okay you
probably disagree with me you think it's
9 right I think it's all worth watching
I love my former bosses there's a lot of
really funny yes no I do think people
really come down too hard on the later
seasons there are gems in there I think
it goes back to that thing of like it
was such a phenomenon back then and then
like that crew that that Sam Simon
assembled was like this master crew yeah
you know like that and when you work on
a show too for like 10 years and stuff
you know like 10 years into screen
junkies or 25 the 25th season of screen
junkies yeah yeah what are you gonna do
this ha ha oh it's gonna be fresh and ha
ha ha ha ha kill me now
uh now I want to talk about some of your
favorites all right ah yeah yeah it's
like yeah I hope that the internet
community doesn't hate me I wrote them
all down yeah I got them off the top of
my head I do look them up but yeah my
lemon of Troy oh my god it's just one of
my favorite is it really we're gonna
have all the same ones
I just watch that the other day yes it
starts off and there's the lemon tree on
the springfield side so Shelbyville
steals the actual lemon tree I am going
to teach some kids a lesson I choose to
take that literally both generations
become involved it's like a story that
involves like the entire yeah it's great
yes eat all of our shirts what so what's
one of your okay
my favorite is Lisa on ice from season
six you are not in competition with each
other
hey a pooch is called this Friday Lisa's
team is playing bards team you're in
direct competition the whole town is
rooting for them to like kill each other
basically and then they just throw it
down they remember the good parts about
being brother and sister and they quit
and they and there's just something
about that are you like every time you
kind of want to pick me up you don't
watch just one of the joke heavy
episodes you watch one of the ones that
you're like that makes me feel good in
general there's human connections in
these animated yeah exactly give me
another one on your list okay so I love
last exit to Springfield I move that
Homer Simpson be out do you need
president Lisa needs braces
and they have like a union kind of
meeting we get a free keg of beer from
me yeah exchange for that we have to
give up a dental plan he remembers the
dental plan Li's yes braces March is
like battle plan Lisa needs braces
battle plan Lisa needs braces when Homer
I love Homer because he's such an oaf
but he cares it works so well because
otherwise if you don't if you don't have
that kind of a person tied into anything
they're just annoying yeah they're just
stupid for the sake of stupid I'm
beginning to think that Homer Simpson
was not the brilliant tactician I
thought he was and another what you'd
mention water Oh summer four foot two is
one of my my favorite they take a summer
vacation down to pretty much Cape Cod
and Lisa's like it's my chance to become
like cool you like hanging out too well
it beats doing yeah yeah stuff sucks one
of my favorite screenshot jokes actually
is that one where it's like when they're
playing the
what's the date game oh is it the dating
game you had a little board game and
they're playing with Milhouse
and like Homer brings a card up and then
you see you see it slowly occur to him
that it looks like Milhouse and it's
just really funny to watch an animated
character to come to a slow realization
and then he's like it looks just like
you Poindexter I remembered my last one
that I think you will like oh man yeah
please
it's the Hank Scorpio episode oh that's
a great one yeah you like those
moccasins look in your closet there's a
pair for you don't like them then
neither do I get the hell out of here he
turns out to be a super villain that
homers working for and it's just it's
really great my family wants to move
back this Springfield let them go you'll
stay here with me we'll go bowling
what's bothering me
alright so let me throw this out there
you both have listed many of your
favorite episodes and there so it is a
tough choice we didn't mention ones like
Marge vs. the monorail or mr. plow and
just there's so many but monorail is
given yeah yeah yeah there is some
weirdo holding a gun to your head saying
tell me your favorite Simpsons episode
the best episode of all time Hayley the
best episode of all time is Springfield
OR how I learned to stop worrying and
start loving you Mike Mitchell the same
weirdo busts into your house in the
middle of the night puts the gun to your
head I would say Springfield as well I'm
with Haley
we're agreeing on it today are you sure
this is the casino I think I should call
my manager your manager says for you to
shut up
veera said that mr. burns puts a casino
in the town yes in Marge is kind of anti
actually I think it might really help
our economy and then she goes and visits
and she and she wins the slot machine
yeah and you can see the fever start to
hell yeah you're spending too much time
at the casino and I think you may have a
problem
I won $60 last night no problem so you
got to see Homer be like the mother hen
for the episode he was in charge of the
children and terrible terrible job hello
Florida I'm not a stage I'm a monster
that episode is in my opinion the most
perfectly executed half hour of
television
oh wow that I've ever seen it's just
really good okay okay wow it's one of
the best no bold statements buddy those
are my quarters hey this guy's paying
off okay
fight it out best season of The Simpsons
ever I'm kind of a six man I don't know
I don't know yeah mi v is great v mercy
this is it I know there's a lot of four
and eight uh heads out there I love a
but for me it loses a little bit of the
classic Ness I know that's kind of a lot
of people will say that's like
blasphemous well I feel the same way
there's something that happens in like
season seven where the Simpsons becomes
like shiny or something like like and I
and I love season seven seven is so
solid yeah yeah but then like a season
six just like it's just like kind of
still has that classic vibe yeah who
shot mr. burns oh yeah and that's like
yeah we thought it was the baby so you
say season five yeah I mean you're six
but I'm not against six I guess yeah
like God is really really really solid
hey Mark it's an elephant nothing
they're both great once you guys shake
hands on that hey great I'm sorry we
didn't give him more con okay okay
no I mean we can all agree that we just
yeah there's so much good stuff yeah you
have both proven yourself to be massive
Simpson heads both of you
oh and just what fun conversation you
guys blew me away with your love for the
show
Haley Mancini Mike Mitchell thank you
both for being thank you for having us
Oh totally was a nice talking to those
guys that conversation was excellent
so what's your favorite Simpsons episode
of all time let us know in the comment
section below and while you're at it any
favorite side characters or guest stars
that we didn't mention I like Jasper
beat this episode is brought to you by
Best Buy
where you can experience the best in
Ultra HD TVs check out the sweepstakes
link in the description below and enter
for a chance to win an amazing Ultra HD
TV from screen junkies thanks for
watching the show I'm Hal Rudnick hit me
up on Twitter bye bye
the whole point of Watchmen is playing
with the form of conference of graphic
novels and when they just try to
translate that over a lot of it didn't
work one of my favorites is a scuf poem
versus the world which goes the other
way really successfully